about three weeks ago i said you'll know
that there's some
tension or a little bit of elbow room
when you start seeing background quotes
from
somebody close to the white house or
within the white house
who says something about uh kamala
harris that would make it
clear that she is the vice president
and so when i saw that i'm like that to
me that was kind of like it was kind of
the first time
you had seen a little bit of a brush
back pitch
and i don't know what's going on
internally because you never see anybody
they don't talk they don't do anything
um but that was definitely a little bit
of a just remember
i and also if i were if i were calmly
harassed i'd be mad
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former white house press secretary to
george w
bush co-anchor of america's newsroom and
co-host
of the five on fox news and author of
the new book
everything will be okay life lessons for
young women
from a former young woman dana parrino
welcome back to the reuben report
honored to be here thanks for having me
you are
a busy lady and before we get to any
of that busy stuff most importantly how
is your dog jasper i
i could do just an hour on dogs in
jasper with you how's he doing
it's actually one of the ways that you
and i first connected right um was dogs
um
and i see that great picture of clyde uh
is that clyde there in the picture
behind you that's
that's actually emma that was emma okay
but they look they look like bizarrely
similar which is a total coincidence i
remember when clyde came into your life
it was like wait this is
this is perfect and you weren't
anticipating you weren't planning it but
it all worked out great
um so jasper's great um he is going to
be nine in april
um in late january he came out of the
bedroom one morning
and was walking real strange tail down
hair up obviously
you know your dog you know something's
wrong but yeah fortunately they can't
tell you what's wrong
so we took them to the vet uh they did a
check
there was a small tumor a
malignant tumor on a smaller intestine
they removed that through surgery and
then we've waited quite a while to find
out what the biopsy results
were because they said it was either a
very common
malignant tumor or a very rare one if it
was a very rare one
that was going to be very tough news bad
news
but it turned out it was the common one
the surgery was successful and we're
just going to wait and see what the
oncologist says if there's anything else
we need to do
but judging by the way that these tumors
usually go
he should be fine and i would say about
12 days after the surgery
he made this remarkable turnaround and
all of a sudden he was back to being his
very athletic
affectionate silly self and um so
we're thrilled thanks for asking yeah do
you ever find that when you post
pictures of jasper or just any of the
personal stuff that in a way
people care a lot more about that than
just sort of
you know what dana might think about
congress voted
two votes extra this way that way the
other thing like there is some
other connection and i think this is in
some ways partly what the book's about
like that people want something else
beyond just the bludgeoning of politics
yeah and one of the things um that i you
know i have a rule no
no politics at the dog park
animals our love for them our dominion
over them
is something so special in life and i
grew up on a ranch
so all the animals were special but the
dogs and the horses
are really special you have that
connection with them that eye contact
that love
i guess some people feel that way about
cats too can't say i ever had the same
experience so i grew up with cats as
well
yeah but i do find that there is a way
to connect with people that you know
like donna brazile and i
um we were we've been friends for a long
time ever since
hurricane katrina and she worked with uh
the bush administration
on restoring new orleans but we really
bonded over
our dogs and we both had different dogs
our previous dogs
when we first knew each other sort of
like you and me uh in a way and then
yeah you know dogs unfortunately they
they don't live as long as we would like
and then the best way to heal your heart
is to get another dog
so i think it's been good and also you
this year has been awful for so many
reasons in terms of the pandemic but
the fact that many families have now
or even single people have emptied the
dog shelters
and adopted dogs as i know you have done
and advocate for adoption
and i'll tell you i think that makes for
a
for kinder people over time
yeah i'm with you i mean you know the
story i i heard the lockdowns were
happening and they were going to put all
these dogs down
i ran to the shelter they had the thing
signed
clyde was being put he was unnamed
unnamed dog being put down that day and
we snagged him and
and he's doing okay so so before we get
into the book let's talk a little bit
about just kind of
what's going on in the world it's been a
it's been a weird year to say the least
um
well actually let's talk about sort of
for your former job for a second because
press secretary
and jen pasake um i i've been giving her
a bit of a hard time on the show she
doesn't
seem particularly well equipped to do
this job she's always circling back
a lot of lot of non-answers i i suspect
you've got
non-answers
and she's perfected that art i suppose
but i'm guessing you have sensitivity
i have a different view look um look
they've only been in office for six
weeks
there is a lot you don't know and that's
one of the reasons you would want to
circle back
she does come to the job with a lot more
experience than i had
because she was the spokesperson at the
state department under president obama
and that gave her two things one a deep
dive into foreign policy
which a lot of people don't necessarily
have unless you've come up through
you know that industry or that um
department
it you have it takes a while to learn
all of those issues um
and she used to get a really hard time
from
a few reporters in particular james
rosen was one of them
from fox news but matt lee of the
associated press
he is an equal opportunity uh
tough reporter on everybody and they
used to have a lot of tangles and
remember she also got caught up in that
whole thing of spying on james rosen and
reporters
so she she comes to the job with a
little bit more
experience than many press secretaries
um
up to date um the other thing is if she
has a press corps
that is one there's not many people in
the room
because they are very strict on covet
protocol so there's probably i think
i think there's like 10 reporters total
in the room that
that makes it for a very different room
masks
also i think are a real barrier to
communication and
um even though somebody might try to
like hold their mask away
there's this whole thing going on with
you can't read lips you can't read
expressions there's all that
um and the other thing is i think
president biden is quite happy
not to drive the news and it's a weird
thing
because i think well you have the
opportunity why wouldn't you drive the
news every single day
they seem to have this belief and we'll
see how it turns out for them that
that they can do their jobs in a very
steady easy way and i use that
kind of phrasing because that feels like
the pace of the administration
is that partly just because the media
kind of likes them perhaps a bit more
than they like that trump fella so
you know they're not going to ride them
as hard it makes their job a little bit
easier
i have a different way of answering this
and i haven't
thought of this until just now because
i've really been asked but
if you think back to the press
secretaries
everyone kind of represents their boss
very well
right so think of ari fleischer
tony snow and me um scott mcclellan
we had the confidence of george w bush
you think of the press secretaries even
though
sean spicer was not press secretary for
very long he continues to be a part of
president trump's
um sort of orbit i would say uh the
other press secretary stephanie grisham
a little bit different she never or she
never briefed that might be a little bit
of a different one
but i think that jen saki is just kind
of in the
approach tone attitude
of joe biden and so
maybe what you want from a press
secretary
uh one you might want some more answers
always
but you also want to know that what you
are getting from that press secretary is
what the president is thinking and how
he thought about it how they got to that
decision
i think that she's actually doing that
yeah do you sense that biden is actually
in charge of this operation because it
doesn't
really seem like he is i mean i hear
what you're saying
but i remember so many times do you
remember
how they said that carl was karl rove
was bush's brain
or that really cheney was really the one
in charge of everything
it wasn't true and i i think about this
now you know the other day when they
uh did the attack on the iranian forces
in syria
did you see the news that um they didn't
tell kamala harris until after
so to me i think yeah i think that he
is in charge yeah when you see something
like that get leaked not that they did
the attack but that
the vice president didn't no yeah what
do you make of like that process because
it seems to me that there's got to be
something going on there that allows
that to get like that's the story in an
odd way
more than you know bombing a random
caravan i think you're with me love
talking to you because
nobody else has brought that up yes okay
this biden team has been the most
tight-lipped disciplined
no leaks no backbiting i mean people are
kind of bored
like wait we used to get what happens
even in any administration you would get
a little bit of that
but on the campaign trail they were very
disciplined
and i think that's partly because they
keep their circles so
small but really pretty interesting that
even as it grew from the primary
campaign into the general election still
no leaks hardly any background you
didn't get any color like
what's going on over there about three
weeks ago i said
you'll know that there's some tension or
a little bit of elbow
room when you start seeing background
quotes
from somebody close to the white house
or within the white house
who says something about uh kamala
harris
that would make it clear that she is the
vice president
and so when i saw that i'm like that to
me that was kind of like it was kind of
the first time
you had seen a little bit of a brush
back pitch
and i don't know what's going on
internally because you never see anybody
they don't talk they don't do anything
um but that was definitely a little bit
of a just remember
i and also if i were if i were kamla
harris i'd be mad
and then what have happened is you have
west wing versus vice president's office
there's always a little
tension there even though they they
handle it pretty well
so far and joe biden is actually quite
um
i'm gonna say solicitous but he tries to
be very inclusive of kamala harris
so even though he is the president he
will say
i did this and he'll stop himself saying
we did this and i think that's a little
bit out of respect
um and also maybe just his management
style that he
wants it to look like there's a team and
a shared effort and i think time will
tell
it's a little early to say so so while
you're giving these guys
credit on sort of the the competency of
how they're managing the thing
how do you think we're doing on the
unity and healing front
which we that that was the meme we got
starting on january 1st well really i
guess on the 20th
but really it's starting at the top of
the year it was like okay 2020 is gone
now we can begin the the year of unity
and healing that was the messaging for a
while we're not really hearing about it
anymore but
i i never felt that it really had any
had any value because we know if the
shoe had been on the other foot
this certainly wouldn't have been about
unity and healing
and uh the bipartisan effort to try to
do
a covet relief plan that they are now
calling the american rescue package
um that was like the whole idea was that
we're going to do this together
and pretty quickly it was clear that ron
clayne who is the chief of staff
is not for that at all um again there's
a little bit of color
from the meeting that um remember when
several of those
republicans susan collins romney portman
um about seven of them they go to the
oval office to have a meeting with joe
biden to say
hey look you save 1.9 trillion we say
600 billion let's talk like maybe we can
figure out some things
and susan collins the senator from maine
reports that during that entire meeting
ron klain sat you know to the
president's side
out of out of eyesight from biden
and shaking his head the whole time nope
nope
and she said she knew in that meeting
they have no intention of making this
a bipartisan effort of course they would
love for some republicans to say oh yeah
sure okay
we'll do that um
it's interesting unity when you in any
general election you can find that the
majority of people
vast majority people will say they want
congress to work together to get along
to do
the right thing together and move the
country forward and
then that lasts for about three days in
this case it didn't even get there
at the time so it looks like we're going
to get 1.9 trillion dollars
of spending by a very slim majority of
democrats
and i don't think that you'll get i
don't think you'll get any republicans
to vote for it in the end
right so as someone that worked in the
government and had to like manage
messaging and stuff when they come up
with these numbers okay we want 600
billion we want 1.9
trillion it's like doesn't it all kind
of feel
made up like that like where are these
numbers really coming from who's really
paying for it like
that there's never a cost there's never
a cost to be like i'm the guy that wants
to cut some stuff so
you'd never do it because or there's no
there's never a benefit in other words
like i'm going to cut some stuff no
one's going to really give you credit
people just want more and more and more
and more
yeah so you imagine that ron claine
would say
we can do 1.9 trillion dollars but don't
you
dare think about going to two trillion
dollars because two trillion dollars
into the year is like that's why things
cost 9.99 at the store
you know that's they don't cost 10
because you'd be like well i'm not going
to pay 10
but 9.99 that sounds that's reasonable
um
in some and i think with the democrats
thing when you the more you look at this
bill
there's very little little that's
specific for coveted relief and they
have a particular philosophy and they're
sticking to it they think that the
stimulus bill that obama passed in 2009
was way too small
and that it did not do enough to help
the economy and that was one of the
reasons that they say
that the economy stalled they don't talk
about the regulations
that they put on businesses all the
things that they were trying to do
to engineer the economy as the problem
they
think that not passing more stimulus in
2009 was what hurt obama
and ron klain came into this saying that
we are not going to go too small that
the danger of
going too small is worse than the risk
of spending too much
that's that's our position but if you
start going through this bill i just
read this piece today by isaac shore in
national review
there's a provision in there for federal
employees to be given
21 000 additional
if their children have had to do school
from home and that's been a hardship for
them
it's outrageous you check that out i
mean there's the swamp
i think that's what we call the swamp is
that what we call this that is that is
so much the swamp isaac shore national
review check that one out
there's the things like the hundred
million dollars for
the bridge that chuck schumer wants uh
in canada there's the 100 million
dollars that um
nancy pelosi wants for that
transportation project from san
francisco out to
silicon valley where i thought everybody
was working from home now so why do we
need that
um actually they've all moved to miami
that's the real truth
right so that they could save on on
taxes
um there is so much in this bill that
has
nothing to do with covet relief and
what what think back to what
happened what was born out of the
stimulus package in 2009
the tea party you know they
they got the grass roots attention i
have a feeling that this could be the
same thing now i also
absolutely believe that there are many
people who have suffered
in this pandemic through no fault of
their own a lot of restaurant owners
uh waitresses um people that worked in
the
hospitality and we could target specific
money to
them but you go through this and it is a
big
wish list and part of the thing is that
republicans
um disagreeing amongst each other that's
normal it's gonna happen
but that is like catnip for reporters
they're always going to report on that
they don't do it as much with the
democrats though they have
lots of differences amongst themselves
but republicans
have not really been able to figure out
a way to drive a message about this bill
and i don't know how you feel about this
dave but the the
the legislation as written has a 73
approval rating
across the country well i think to me
it's just that people don't
know what's in anything it's sort of
what you're saying and it's like oh you
see a high number so you're like oh
i kind of don't know where the money
comes from but i guess it doesn't come
from me and they'll just take it from
somewhere and then if it's a high number
that means i'll get more so no
politician
ever wants to be the one well i guess
there's probably one guy that kind of
does it every now and again which is
rand paul
is the one guy that's like oh maybe we
can't pay for all of this or maybe we
shouldn't be doing all this stuff
and that's just sort of how politics
works and then you sound mean uh
if you're if you're right then you're
mean and cold
that's right yeah and then you know and
we're about to see like right after this
um they're going to pass a
infrastructure bill too
and it will be probably four trillion
dollars
do you think that the democrats
basically fundamentally believe that you
at this point that you can just print
money endlessly because i i just have
come to that like they don't there's no
economic principle for any of this and
by the way it's not like the republicans
are so great they
you know trump cut taxes and also the
budget exploded too so like
they're all guilty but i think more
fundamentally it seems the democrats
believe that you can just print print
print print money
which also makes their position on taxes
a little weird because then why would
you always be raising taxes on the rich
unless it's purely to punish them right
if you if you can just print money
in an unlimited supply then why do you
have to punish people too well i guess
if you if you just need an
enemy to point that but do you think
that or is that all of government at
this point which is just ah we'll just
make up numbers and just keep printing
and
you know we'll go as we'll go as far as
we can until the end until we ride right
off the cliff well not only that but i
don't think that you have many people in
business telling them not to
yeah right so so who's who's standing
a thwart saying no um you know a few
congressmen and people on fox news it's
probably not gonna they're not gonna cut
it
um and republicans are also guilty but
look the law of economics
it's called law for a reason the laws of
economics haven't changed
um i do i think the democrats think they
can print money but
also i think that they think they can
tax their way out of this problem
but i'll tell you one thing about that
if you go back to
obama era and when the bush tax cuts
were going to expire
they actually kept them because
economically they knew that
that would actually hurt economic growth
even more
raising taxes at that time so i don't
know how they're going to
raise all this money i mean hope hope is
not a plan
yeah and that you don't want your
accountant to be hopeful
right um and that's what we're dealing
with right now
right so before we get to the book i
want to ask you a little bit about uh
you've had a couple changes kind of in
your in your day-to-day
shifting around your schedule and you're
doing like 87 shows and all kinds of
stuff but i also want to ask you about
um fox and kind of what's going on over
there because
i still hear this a lot when i go on fox
like there's a certain amount of people
that are just sort of pissed at fox that
a year ago
were not pissed at fox do you hear any
of that do you think any of the
criticisms legit
not so much anymore no i mean obviously
i heard a lot about that you know right
after
the election but i think now that the
new administration is underway and
there's a lot of new programming fresh
programming here at fox um it's kind of
some exciting um
programming uh of course you know in
that seven o'clock hour
uh rotating host right now um lawrence
jones was uh hosting this week yeah did
a great job last night
trey gowdy's been great rachel campos
duffy was good katie pavlich i guess i'm
like wow we have a lot of talent here
and so that's great
my job changed in that um i was doing
the daily briefing with dana perino at
two o'clock which i loved you know when
you could come on as a guest
and then the five which i've done for
nearly 10 years now can you believe it
10 years in july that's crazy it's
absolutely crazy
yeah because jasper's nine that's always
keep track so that we started in july of
2011.
um so in december just as i'm finishing
up this book
just as the elections you know sort of
behind us um
i think i'll have a relaxing time get
covered behind us with these vaccines
and they get a call saying we have an
idea like oh
i love ideas what's your idea and it was
um for me to no longer do
america's excuse me uh the daily
briefing but to
co-anchor america's newsroom with bill
hemmer from 9 to 11 in the morning
i was shocked pleasantly so
um i love bill hemmer i actually am one
of those annoying people that loves
mornings
um i like doing that news first of the
day
and i have to so we've been doing it
since january 18th and it has been
such a joy i love it and you know we do
um a lot of cal
more about california uh which i think
we should i think as a nation we should
all be focusing a little bit more on
the country as a whole and also in
california and i'd be curious you know
that we're on nine to 11 so that's six
to eight your time i don't know what
time you all are
getting up and watching any news but
we're getting some pretty good feedback
out of california got some good numbers
the harder thing for me i think right
now is figuring out
how to actually manage the length of my
day like one of the things i write about
in the book is about
work life balance and time management
and taking control of that and making
good personal decisions
so having the 9 to 11 a.m show which i
get up at 4 30
to prepare for that um then having those
few hours in between that and the five
which i need at least an hour and a half
to prepare for the five i think
maybe an hour but hour and a half um
it's kind of hard to like
what where else can you find time to do
things so that's that's been a little
bit difficult
yeah so with your schedule change well
first off you know on the on the
california part and and doing an earlier
show you know i tweeted this the other
day but
we have something like 2 million out of
the 1.5 million necessary signatures to
recall gavin newsom
and i'm pretty sure that cnn has not
uh run astoria yeah
right you would you know you guys have
covered it that's my point that it's
like fox covers it
but if you were just watching mainstream
media
you would have no idea that the governor
from the largest state
in the union the tenth biggest economy
in the world something like that
is going to be recalled it's going to
happen
so they're they're right now they have
about 2 million of and they only needed
1.5 we know that because it's a
one-party state
when they're going through all the
signatures they're going to pull all
sorts of craziness
but i think having 500 000
extra and we still have about a week a
week to get more so it's gonna happen
but the fact that like that just doesn't
get covered
sort of shows you why we're in such a
polarized world
yeah and also just the the economic
weight of california
both for the good and the bad right uh
if this coveted relief bill passes
i think california stands to get 70
billion dollars
i mean i'm sure we'll spend it well i'm
sure you know what i think is very
interesting
about the recall is is the bipartisan
nature or the not i sort of feel like
it's a nonpartisan issue
as i understand it a lot of those
signatures are being driven by
parents of kids uh that they want their
kids back in school and there's the
hypocrisy
of the elites who will put their i can
afford to put their kids in private
school
but keep the public schools closed and
the small business owners and the
restaurants who have just like
fed up like and never made sense to me
the closing of outdoor dining in
california is insane
dana i'm you know i'm i'm in la it's 80
and sunny
every single day not only did we have
outdoor clothes dining we're still the
last state that has out closed indoor
dining which
at that point you can have 35 indoor
dining
right so new york where it's freezing
cold right now you can have 30
35 indoor we have still closed outdoor i
mean and we know that gavin newsom is
still going out to his dinners and
and all of that craziness but all right
don't get me started on la because then
you'll get ready to run for governor
watch yourself
they want we'll see look let the recall
happen you know i think i jokingly said
it it might have been on your show i
like kind of half
said it like six months ago that i would
maybe run and then
every everywhere i go now everybody
asked me let's get the guy recalled
and then and then we'll go from there
how about that you would be a very
attractive candidate and i don't just
mean aesthetically but of course it's
true
um but you know
dave we need people to want to run for
office and i can ask
why so you're you you know this why
would a good
person want to put up with the insanity
to me when when for the few minutes that
david and i have really discussed it
like could i actually do it
um it's more about all of the heart not
not the management
not not about knowing the ideas and what
i would want to do and all that stuff
it's about the horror show related to
the media
and the destruction of personal life and
everything else so as a person that
would clean that stuff up
what kind of advice would you give
someone that would even consider it
well okay
if you are going to do it one of the
things you have to do
and like if you're serious about it you
have to ask somebody
with competence perhaps a friend to do
a very thorough opposition research
dump on you for your own personal
consumption
so and and that then you can look at it
and say oh yeah that was
yeah i was still oh yeah i did all right
very good
you got to feel and you got to see what
it is you have to be very honest with
yourself because in today's day and age
the competition is fierce you're going
to face a lot of
negativity and people could bring things
up from your from your past
a lot of women will shy away
that's one of the reasons that like
elise stefanik the congressman from new
york
they focus specifically on helping women
who think they want to run for
um office but are concerned about
something coming up in their past and
hurting their current family
and they also are very reluctant to ask
to raise money
you that's one i think the hardest
things that people have i think you
might have a hard time with that too
you got to call up your friends and
jawbone them and get them to give you a
million dollars
for your campaign that might not win
yeah and so that's hard um
so i but i do think that if people are
thinking about running
if you have a loving relationship
a great family that is going to stand by
you no matter what
you can do it you can get through it
i think i'm going to stick on youtube
for now
for now unless you're looking to get
back in the game and if you want to be
my chief of staff or something then we
can
i'd be a very good chief of staff i
would not be a good candidate i'd be a
great chief of staff though i'd be like
ron clayne in the background going
nope nope yeah exactly exactly so let's
let's shift to your book a little bit
because
you were talking about sort of your
schedule change and managing your life
and everything else
and when i was reading through this this
morning and i've got it right here um
i i had there's a certain sort of jordan
peterson
feel to this about getting your life in
order but
you know you're obviously aiming this
more towards young women
now you say you say from a former young
woman am i allowed to ask a tv host how
old they are is that a question they're
sure so i love the subtitle it makes me
laugh every time and i also think
it's true like so i'll be 49 this year
so that's like you're still pretty young
kind of because you know this
but you think about people like what do
you learn from
let's say 22 when you start your first
job
to 49 is a lot you know you you go
through
a lot and i get asked by a lot of
younger people for
advice as they're trying to climb their
way up the ladder or
try to get their sort of their life
together and i'm so i wrote the book
because all those young women that come
in my office
i could do it all day long i could have
a mentoring business
just sitting here taking calls giving
advice
but i just noticed that they would worry
so much
and they want a specific plan which
specific plans do not exist
um you can have you can put yourself in
the right direction so when i say in the
title everything will be okay
that is true but you have to
do some things to make it that way you
have to make good
good personal decisions time management
i think that there's a lot of freedom in
discipline
and having some principles and
parameters in your life that can help
you but
there's really ambitious amazing young
people out there
and especially for young women if you're
born in america
first of all you already won life's
great lottery
yeah you're good if you are an educated
american woman
then all you got to decide right now is
how responsible do you want to be and
how hard do you want to work
because you're in the driver's seat and
i don't think a lot of them realize that
you know a lot of them think that um
that the guys are always going to
be promoted over the gals that's not
true that the guys are going to get
the promotions and the raises anymore
that's not true
many women are now the primary
breadwinner of their families
and so there's we're in a little bit of
a cultural shift there
and it is time to step up
to be a leader to be a manager you got
to show that you're able and willing to
do it and resilient the pandemic adds
another wrinkle
how do you network uh in in a pandemic
how do you get face time with the boss
how do you figure out what your next
move is um so i talk about all sorts of
those things in the book
yeah do you think that the pandemic did
anything
broadly speaking to women in a different
way than it did
so perhaps being home or homeschooling
whatever you might be cooking all those
things again of course they're not
exclusive
to women but as you know because i
toured with jordan i saw
what so many young men were dealing with
and now this is more about what young
women are dealing with throw in a
pandemic where everybody's back in the
house
and and it's very different yes some of
the statistics
about how many women have left the
workforce will just blow your mind
that there are less women in the
workforce now than there were some like
30 years ago
now they'll come back that will come
back but what do you lose in that time
frame
right because new colleagues come new
technology is introduced we have a new
software system here i don't even know
i don't even understand it um but you
have to get trained on on those things
um you come back to the workforce and
all of a sudden they want to cut your
salary by ten
thousand dollars um because you were at
home now what's happened is
the reason a lot of women have left the
workforce is because kids aren't in
school
so if kids aren't in school it usually
will fall
to the woman the mother to be the one
that stays home to help with the
um work from home schedule sit on the
zoom uh
take care of the family and and women
have made a lot of sacrifices men too
then too um but from the workplace
perspective yes
if i could give one piece of advice that
i talked to
that i talked about in the book a
girlfriend of mine was a global talent
officer for a big pr firm
and she has three boys and she's one of
the most friends that i look at is
how in the world does she do it all one
of those friends
so i asked her about this um issue with
women
this is true regardless of the pandemic
let's say that you're going to have to
take a break from work
whether because of kids work from home
or maybe
you decide that you want to spend
the first few years of your child's life
at home and not at the workplace when
you decide to go back to the workplace
it's almost always true that women will
be looked at as a
difficult hire because they might not be
available you know all the time
work work share is a great idea and some
companies are doing it well the pandemic
has helped
a little bit to make some for some more
flexibility um
but there will be a gap in your resume
right so it'll be like i worked here i
worked here but then there's this gap
and now you're coming back to the
workplace oftentimes what michelle told
me is that
they will be demoted or cut in salary
something like that so she has this
great recommendation i tell everybody
about this and it's true for same-sex
couples too if you
similar situation if you are going to
take some time off from work to help
raise
a baby she says if you're going to take
time off
start an llc a little small business
easy to set up
pretty inexpensive really i don't know
about california prices but i think in
new jersey it's like 250
i think delaware you want to do it in
delaware good point
and she said have a little business so i
would call mine like dana perino
communications
and you have a little bit of
opportunity then to take on a client or
two or a project here and there
but when you go back to the workforce
you will not have a a work gap
you will have an entrepreneurial
addition
to the resume so that the chances of you
being knocked back
either from a responsibility standpoint
or salary
is greatly decreased and i thought that
was such good advice i try to mention it
always
so how much of of what you have in the
book really is just sort of like think
about your life
clearly because it seems to me that a
lot of young people
especially because of what's happened in
the last year not only does the future
just look very murky like the future of
the country the future
of their lives like a career you know
any of that kind of stuff
but also they're they don't know like
what
what they want in a sense of like young
women maybe they're
they've been trained for too long to put
too much emphasis
on career instead of family same could
go yeah for young men that that the
where they're always being aimed at like
if you if you were a young woman and you
were just like
i just want to be the best homemaker and
wife that i can be
and teach my kids and and cook and keep
a great house
that's a very that's a very lofty thing
my mom raised three kids
she did not work when she was raising us
but then did go back to work afterwards
she worked before and then but had like
a 20-year gap on that while she was
raising three kids
to me that was a beautiful thing but
like if you if you say that as a woman
now it's kind of scoffed at by the
mainstream
yes though i think that's changing a
little bit
i do especially as women now have more
choices right so
as i mentioned a lot of women are now
the primary breadwinner so that's
actually
there's all there's a cultural shift
happening there too um
do you have a life partner that is uh
okay with that
you know and supportive and i think that
that is that is
changing just a little bit i have a
piece of advice in there that i call the
whiteboard
incident and it's because of something
that peter did with me
when i was in san diego when we lived in
san diego um
i really wanted to work for george w
bush i wanted to get back to washington
dc where i had worked before
didn't quite know how to do it i was
working in pr
really didn't enjoy it and i couldn't
really see how to get ahead
and we lived in san diego which is where
everybody would love to live except
you're in l.a that's
the other place people want to live san
diego sounds pretty sweet these days so
it's
compared to what's going on in l.a yeah
and the mayor of kevin faulconer
did a pretty good job there during covet
and he's uh he could be your competition
if you run for governor
i know i know so i went to dc i met with
a few people networked
with folks that i used to work with on
capitol hill at that time it was august
of 19
sorry august of 2001. and then most of
the jobs were filled but they'd keep an
eye out for me and i come home and
i think i just really want to do this so
peter says let's
let's do an experiment he gets the white
board out with this little
erasable marker he says tell me all the
things you want to do in a job
so i listed the things i like to do in
my work
tell me all the things you don't want to
do in a job so i listed all of those
things
and then we assigned a value to those
things
and then it became very clear you add it
up
staying in san diego was like a zero
doing anything in dc was like a nine
i'm like oh when you look at it that way
interesting
i also mentored a young woman not too
long ago and she was sort of following
in the footsteps of her family
of medical professionals and
at the end of the chat i said
if if you weren't going to do this what
would you do
she goes oh i am so into
psychology and i bought these books and
i've read all these things
and i've been listening to the podcast
and i was thinking about getting a
master's degree because i'm just so
interested in it but
i said well wait maybe you should be
doing that
right right and so
there's just so much freedom now for
people uh to be able to do so many
different things
one last story i'll mention um there's a
young woman that i know
who uh graduated in december of 2019
in event management okay she gets a job
she's here in new york she's going to do
events
and she worked she was working for a
company that did events all over the
city big
events like runway type things fashion
week things like that
and what happens in february of the end
of february 2020
no events and the
i think that we are now on our one-year
anniversary of our two-week lockdown
yep so she lost her job
she also ended up with a skein injury
like
um so she went home to live with her
parents
and she could have been quite despondent
but she was watching these nurses and
doctors and she knew that
in her area in new jersey they needed
more masks her mother
grandmother was an interior designer who
had retired she had all this extra
fabric
so she had a sewing machine and she's
kind of hand so while she was recovering
from her surgery she just made masks
all day long making masks donating them
around but they were super cute
so then people like where can i get one
of those we're gonna so she started
selling the masks
and then she ended up with so much
business that she hired a couple of
other young women to work for her and
then she bought an embroidery machine
and now she's been doing that and who
knows if she'll ever go back to
event management you know she's she
found a whole new thing and i love the
resilience
and and the spirit and also she was
unconditionally
loved by her family and it's okay to
rely
on your family in times like this
yeah and that's one of the things that's
been so hard for people because in many
cases we're
we're seriously separated yeah from our
family i actually haven't seen my
parents
since this began because they finally
just got the vaccines
and you know they're in their early 70s
so it just wasn't gonna happen i'm
finally gonna see them in a couple of
weeks
but just lose i think losing that
connection because you know
people think it can be replaced by
facetime and zoom and it just can't
no and the other thing that's happened
for a lot of young people when you're on
zoom all the time is um
there's a lot of anxiety about your
appearance
obviously i'm i'm in full hair and
makeup from the show i did earlier from
fox news and so
this is not how i would normally be if i
was working from my office
and i wasn't on tv um
the anxiety about performing
and being on camera all the time you
think of a lot of people
are kind of introverts right zoom
gets them way out of their comfort zone
if you have to be on a zoom for three
hours a day with your team
it's been a it's been hard on a lot of
people um
and also presenting in front of that
many people um
instead of just doing it in front of
your team or your board uh in
in the in the media conference room and
you're doing it in front of everybody
and that anxiety about public speaking
is something that
i also talk about especially because um
one thing that's different from
anything that you and jordan would have
talked about um one of the things
one of the pieces of advice i give is
you women have to find their strong
voice
so we have a naturally higher register
um for some especially
on a zoom or on camera or
the voice can be grading
and a lot of young women get into this
habit early on
from their teens and it's kind of
following them into the workplace with i
call it upspeak
yeah talk like this because they're not
really sure about all the things
we just call it valley girl talk
it i'm just telling you you will not get
promoted
or chosen to go meet the new client
or go on the big business trip if you
talk like that
and a lot of people dave they don't even
realize that they're doing it
and and if you can gently point out to
them
that they're speaking this way they'll
turn it around immediately they can turn
it off it's like
well i do that i didn't know i do that
and now when they get with their friends
they could fall back into it but i'm
really
really big on this because i see it i'm
like oh
she'll she doesn't stop that she's never
never going to get promoted
um but that's like that's like one of
the ones that it's kind of hard to say
to somebody these days right because it
feels like an affront
to their to their very being the way you
sound
the way you speak yeah maybe there will
be an hr violation
yeah no that's what i mean like they're
gonna yeah this is my natural affect
but i i i've taken a couple of young
women aside and
you can make it kind of light sweet
i feel like we have an obligation to
help them um if you have someone in your
life if it's your
if it's your daughter or your
granddaughter or your niece or somebody
that works for you
you maybe don't even tell them just give
them the book
and let them see hopefully they'll
they'll come to it
on their own but i'm telling you i know
that this has worked there's a young
woman who used to work for me
who definitely used to do that i also
think it's a sign of
a lack of confidence because if you say
something
in the form of a question then you don't
have to own the opinion
do you see what i mean like i don't know
i'm just asking questions
if you say it that way you don't have to
own it yeah i thought it was a really
interesting part of the book because it
reminded me of sort of why i can't stand
listening to npr
because they do that thing too and
everything
sort of sounds like a question and like
it's never a definitive proclamation
and i can't stand it yeah
i mean actually i don't listen to npr
for a lot of reasons but
um that's one of many many reasons yeah
no but that now that you say that i
realized morning edition yeah on morning
edition though
yeah and even even when they actually
yeah even when they ask the question and
they know what the answer is they still
do it you know what i mean
like it's all scripted
it's the worst kind of scripted so i was
really interested in chapter four
because it's how do you find a role
model and as you may remember chapter
nine of my book was find a mentor
and that was not a chapter that i had
intended to put in my book but
but what happened with me and jordan was
sort of an accidental mentorship i
suppose because we happened to be on
tour together
and it just kind of happened but that
you made a point of saying how do you
find it like this is something that
you've
you've got to do do you think everybody
needs a mentor needs a role model yes i
i do but i don't think that the
relationships have to be as formal
as some people might think a lot of
companies now will have these formal
mentoring programs and that's great
although sometimes i don't think they're
really working like i know this one
program
where there's somebody that works in
production
and they've been paired with somebody
who works in accounting
but the person that does it doesn't
really work now it's good to meet people
around the office and i'm big on
networking and building your network and
meet as many people as you can
um but i yes i'd absolutely think that
you need role models
i think back to my childhood i really
wanted to be an
anchor a news anchor i love diane sawyer
she had worked in the nixon white house
a lot of people don't remember that
i liked how she carried herself her
storytelling her journalism i thought
she had such gravitas and dignity
i also even thought of this is a
fictional character but i love
civil shepherd in moonlighting oh yeah
bruce willis yeah she was the boss lady
and
i sort of like you know there's a saying
in
women's mentoring called or that says
you have to see her to be her
that's another reason you know i like to
i like to do the mentoring um
so i'm constantly finding role models i
have one now that i write about in the
book her name is anne glogg
she's now dame and globe i should say a
self-made
businesswoman in scotland who has the
biggest heart and as
her company stagecoach the busing
company as it's grown internationally
she got the she's with her
her brothers and her splitted up the
responsibilities so they expanded into
europe she did europe and africa
and her brothers did asia and south
america
so she went to africa she had been a
nurse in a they call in england
a burns unit um for i don't know what we
would call it here i don't think we have
a specific name but she treated
people that had wounds from burns and
fire
she goes to africa first of all
she refuses to pay bribes will not do it
and these this has never happened before
in the busing contracts that are ever
happening in kenya
and tanzania and they they said well
then
your buses are not going to be released
from the port and she says
fine and we'll make sure that you're
blamed
and she is tiny i'm short i'm five i
think she's a little smaller than me
really really small person she's got
such guts but what i really also love
about her is her heart
she saw what was happening for early
childhood development and maternal
health in africa and she was just
determined to do something about it
so not only is she just a terrific
businesswoman
i feel like she has such a gracious way
of handling her time her work-life
balance
where she gives a ton
with accountability you know nobody gets
the free money but she has a few clinics
and an orphanage that she runs
um she runs the business and she has i
think
six children and then several that she's
adopted from africa
and i see her as sort of a
pure role model but you know even
somebody
that's a former younger woman um can
have role models to this day because i
always
want to be improving that's why i listen
to you know i watch your show
i listen to podcasts i am constantly
reading
i don't ever want to stop learning and
meeting her and getting to know her has
really enriched my life
wait dana are you telling me you don't
know it all at 49 you haven't perfected
the whole thing
you haven't done it do you know i don't
know if you're like this i feel like i
wake up every day
knowing less than i knew the day before
i feel like the
the universe of knowledge is just
growing so exponentially
i feel i have so much to learn i never
feel like i have read enough and usually
i have read more than anybody else in
the room
but i always feel like i'm a little bit
behind
i i asked my friend who as you know
recently passed larry king i
many times i asked him you know what did
he think the meaning of life was and he
always said the same thing the only
thing i know is that i do not know i do
not know
i just read a book by adam grant called
think again the power of knowing what
you don't know
mm-hmm that was great and it kind of
takes some pressure off you to say like
i don't know i'm curious
let me learn talk to me tell me what you
know how do you see it how do you feel
about it
and that kind of approach i think can
help going back to what we
started with in terms of unity you know
barbara bush had a saying that in a
marriage um both people need to be
willing to go
60 of the way there and
i don't know if in our public discourse
and in our public policy debates
both sides aren't there yet they're not
willing to go 60 of the way there
and i don't know what will help us get
to that point i don't know what
what the issue will be that will help
get us there
yeah i mean unfortunately it's almost
like it has to sort of be something
terrible
like that's the only way we could kind
of come together like the way new york
was after a 911 like yeah because even
the pandemic didn't really do it
no if anything it exacerbated yourself
um
let's talk about the last chapter though
i feel like that would be a good way uh
to wrap uh it's it's called serenity how
can you detox recover and find
peace i feel like pretty much everyone's
looking to find a little piece these
days that you know we're
we're home more we're online more
social media is not making us social uh
the
the
quest for peace doesn't seem to be going
that well for a lot of people right now
well um so i wrote the that chapter
because um
the the serenity prayer was um prominent
in my home
growing up uh as part of the lutheran
church but also my mom
went through a program called children
of alcoholics so that's part of the
a.a system and the serenity prayer is
very important
for recovery and i've known a few people
that have gone through
alcoholics anonymous bob beckel one of
the first people on the five
um he did and it really helped turn his
life around
when i think about serenity i do you
know those moments
dave in your life and they're usually
just glimpses
when you feel like you're right exactly
where you're supposed to be
at the moment they're rare and they're
fleeting
it's such a gift and i feel like that's
what god's intention
was for us to be able to have more of
that and when i
mentor these young women i find that
they're nowhere close to being able to
find that so
i have lots of different suggestions in
that chapter for how somebody
might find it um there's some things
that work for me
um i write a lot of lists uh
and if i feel like i'm being concerned
with consumed with worry or anxiety
on a piece of paper i will write my list
of concerns worries
and then i'll make two columns in that
next column i'll say is this something
that i have control over or not
mark it for the things that i have
control over
i then in the third column make a little
bit of a notation about what i could do
about it
and then i learned this exercise when i
was in college and pretty stressed
i take that piece of paper and i carry
it with me
in my purse in my backpack my back
pocket wherever it might be
so that when i feel that sort of anxiety
bubbling up i can
pull that back out and look at it and
know okay wait wait okay
i've got a plan here for how to deal
with those things i've also found
that guided meditation for me has been
very useful
and then i would say one other thing
which is as you said we're quite
isolated
and we're on these zooms and even though
i love the connection i love being able
to talk to you and to see you like the
in the jetsons
um yeah no well that's the irony of it
right it's like i didn't even know you i
don't think i had ever
i knew who you were obviously for many
years but i don't think i had done your
show until
no maybe i know we did do it in person
once a little bit you were in town yeah
you were in this
but in essence we became friends through
this thing which is a very weird
you know we've never we've never had a
drink together we've never had a meal
together
it's a very weird thing let's do it we
have to you know it wouldn't really help
in washington
i feel like everyone needs to go and get
drunk together
with no phones but like imagine like
you know you could imagine you know ted
cruz is getting drunk with alexandria
cortez they'll probably strike up a
friendship and
maybe be able to get to that unity um
but anyway the other thing that i
started doing a couple of years ago
was an exercise to get out of my own
mind because something i remind people
of here is
just when you think everybody's thinking
about you and you think that they're
thinking negatively about you you have
to remember
no one's thinking about you they are
thinking about themselves
yeah yeah and also i remember
everybody's going through
something everybody look dave you're
going through something
um uh my sister's friend she is going
through
uh she just had a double mastectomy um
thankfully
looks like cancer-free you know peter
and i are going through something
everybody's going through something
so what i started doing is anybody that
i see that i'm
walking by or on the subway when i used
to take the subway
um people that i won't necessarily say
hi to
i'll just say a little prayer for them
so um
like i remember this one lady and her
daughter they were doing homework on the
subway on the way home
i remember you know please help them get
home home safely
um to the guy i hope that he has a
really productive day at work um i hope
that she is treated well by all of her
colleagues i hope no
the guy that works in retail i can't
stand it when anybody is mean to anybody
that works in customer service
and i really like i pray that nobody's
bad to him today or like negative
towards him today
it kind of became a habit that
it really helps me get out of my own
head and out of my own way
um and to sort of spread this kindness
because i really think that that's the
way to reduce anxiety
and increase your ability to be your
full self that will
hopefully open up opportunities and
doors for promotion
raises a change in career or even if you
haven't met that lucky somebody yet
open your heart up up to uh meeting
somebody and making a commitment
well dana that's the perfect ending but
i have to
return the favor that you often offer me
which is to bring clyde
on your show is is jazz no no i don't
need to replied on this is my show
is jasper around her no um i'm i'm at
work
but hold on i'm gonna get something hold
on
so i went on the that book tour with my
jasper book and i bought one of these
this is oh there you go this is felt
jasper
you've got to get a few of these get a
felt clyde oh
they're the best toys the only thing is
jasper really wants to eat this
well jasper should be allowed to eat he
wants this toy so
they're kind of expensive but if you go
on etsy you can send them a picture of
your dog and they'll make you one oh and
they'll
even has like a little little ear
what a world what a world dave all right
guys you're a great american
and a wonderful person thank you
right back at you the book is everything
will be okay and
everything will be okay it really it
really will be there will be uh
i look forward to seeing you in person
and uh good luck
i was gonna say i was about to say good
luck with the rest of the book tour but
good luck sitting in that seat talking
to other people like me i suppose
thanks dave okay bye-bye if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell